كان راسي يامل ان تتحسن الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه في بريطانيا لا سيما بعد تجاوز
جائحه كورونا لكنه وجد نفسه مخيرا بين
الاستمرار في السوق او الاغلاق نهائيا
اقوم بهذا العمل منذ نحو 30 عاما ولم اشهد
وضعا بهذا السوء من قبل فقد اصبح من الصعب
للغايه الاستمرار في العمل في ظل التضخم
وغلاء المواد الاساسيه وفواتير الطاقه
والايجار والضرائب
انا جنبه
في اربعه عقود تتزامن مع ازمه معيشه خانقه
اضعفت القدره الشرائيه للشركات
والمستهلكين على حد سواء
مركز ابحاث تجزئه ان نحو 50 محلا تجاريا
كانت تغلق يوميا بشكل نهائي العام الماضي
اي بزياده تقدر بنحو 50% مقارنه بالعام
2021 لكن يبدو ان الامال بالعوده
مع ظهور تحديات جديده امام الشركات
في حاله عدم الاستقرار الاقتصادي تزيد
الضغوط على الشركات الصغرى التي تعاني
اصلا تداعيات جائعات كورونا ايديغشى نحو
60% منها من الانهيار هذا العام بحسب شركه
تاورغيت للتامين يقول اتحاد الشركات
الصغرى ان ربع اعضائه تقريبا قد يعلنون
افلاسهم او يقلصون انشطهم بعد اذان مارس
مع انتهاء برنامج لدعم الطاقه للشركات
والاسره
في سوق الطاقه العالميه لكننا نعلم ان 20%
من الشركات الصغرى تمرر الزيادات الى
زبائنها وان 24% منها قالت انها ستغلق او
تقلص عملياتها بشكل كبير
كلنا في البرنامج الحكومي لدعم الطاقه 18
مليار جنيه استرليني على مدار سته اشهر
تنتهي في نيسان ابريل المقبل لكن الحكومه
تخطط لتقديم تخفيضات لشركات بقيمه خمسه
مليارات فقط لانها نفسها تواجه ضغوطا لخفض
الدين العام الذي بلغ مستوى القياسيا
يتجاوز التريليون جنيه استرليني وهو ما
يعادل تقريبا حجم الاقتصاد البريطاني
بكامله من حربا الجزيره لندن